if you want to support this channel and
get cool anime merch at the same time
like the dragon sin of Wrath Mele Otis
feel the wrath of my dragon and the lion
sin of pride esken or praise the Sun
check out our online store link in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mac here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about the
master of the Sun himself the lion sin
of pride Eskin or we got a really great
response from you guys on our video
about the two sides of Mele Otis so in
this video we will be talking about the
two drastically different sides of Eskin
or the nervous and easily frightened
human who is by far the weakest of the
seven deadly sins at night versus the
massive juggernaut of manliness who
becomes the strongest out of all the
seven deadly sins at high noon each day
ESCA nor is particularly interesting
because both his physical appearance and
his personality changed drastically
depending on the time of day which makes
for a clear split in his character and
yet in the end both sides are clearly
connected and part of one complete
person and I find this to be extremely
interesting which is why I'm excited to
make this video if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and if you have some seven deadly
sins fan art that you would like to see
featured in a future video or you just
want to give us ideas for future videos
check us out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar now this video does contain
manga spoilers because as of the making
of this video
ESCA noir has just barely been
introduced in the anime and so in order
to give you the full picture about his
character I need to go into the material
from the manga if you don't want any
spoilers you have been warned but if you
are caught up to the manga or you just
don't care about spoilers then let's get
into it
ESCA noir is the last member of the
seven deadly sins that we are introduced
to and we don't officially meet him
until the second half of the second
season of the anime although we do see a
very brief glimpse of him in the final
episode of the signs
holy war OVA esken or is a 40 year old
human and he has a very unique power
which first manifested in his youth at
nighttime
ESCA nor is by far the weakest of the
seven deadly sins he is even weaker than
the average human
and in terms of his personality night
time s canora's quiet bashful and polite
however as the Sun begins to rise each
day
ESCA Norse power grows immensely every
hour until it reaches its maximum height
at noon each day as his power grows his
body also grows he becomes incredibly
tall and muscular until he reaches his
peak at high noon at which point he
towers over regular people both in terms
of stature and in terms of power because
as Connor gets his power from the Sun he
is also known as the master of the Sun
and that is why you will most likely see
the phrase praise the Sun all over the
comments section to this video at noon
each day s Connors power is at its
highest for one minute a state known as
the one and at this point Merlin states
that s Kannur is easily the strongest
out of all the seven deadly sins as he
becomes an invincible incarnation of
power along with his physical appearance
s Connors personality changes
drastically as noon approaches he goes
through a meek and nervous person to an
increasingly arrogant grandiose and
prideful machine of destruction which
explains why s Kannur is the sin of
pride just as an example after he is
able to defeat meliodas in assault mode
Diann says that s Kannur is the
strongest man and that they can all
count on him s Kannur is shocked that
she would say something so foolishly
obvious s Canora has also been known to
tell his opponents to apologize for
being born into the same world as him
the name of esken or sacred treasure is
the divine axe Rita a massive and
insanely heavy battle axe in his daytime
form s Kannur gives off a great amount
of heat which can actually hurt the
people who are in his vicinity but his
sacred treasure allows him to gather all
of that excess energy inside the axe and
then release it when the time is right
scanners power level has been measured
at as low as 15 in his night time form
and as high as 114 thousand which is
just insane in his daytime mode because
his power level fluctuates so much
throughout the day it is virtually
impossible to measure the true extent of
Eskin or power and because of how
immense his power becomes a scanner
still struggles to control it and he is
sometimes known to lose control which he
then later regret like many characters
in the seven deadly sins a scanner has a
very interesting backstory that really
shaped him as a character he was born as
a prince of a Britannia kingdom called
Castelli Oh a scanner Oh had an older
brother who would often mistreat him but
then one day a scanners unique power
awoke inside of him and he broke his
older brother's arm by accident after
this incident and because of the
appearance of his mysterious power the
people of the castello kingdom began to
look at s Canora as some kind of freak
his own parents disowned him and after
the Kingdom soldiers tried to kill him
for being a dangerous monster he was
barely able to escape with his life by
hiding in a barrel and drifting off to
sea inside of it as his power continued
to develop s Kannur was feared and
looked at as a monster everywhere he
went and even when he tried to show
others that he was a good person they
still feared him and rejected him all of
this took a great toll on s Kannur and
he felt ostracized by everyone the one
person who did not see s Kannur as a
dangerous monster was Merlin and when he
met her s Kannur instantly fell in love
with Merlin the one person who was not
afraid of him but actually interested in
his unique power in what is a huge twist
of irony the proud and supremely
confident s Kannur is often shy in front
of Merlin because of his feelings for
her you could even say that he is
insecure about Merlin because he doesn't
know if she will ever feel the same way
about him as he does about her and in
the manga he was even shown to be
jealous of Merlin's relationship with
Arthur Pendragon s karna enjoys writing
poetry including special poems for
Merlin but he is insecure about those as
well and he has been shown to worry
about whether his poems are worthy of
Merlin
actually hearing them askin or special
power is called sunshine we later
learned that sunshine was a blessing or
grace created by the supreme deity the
ruler of the goddess clan and him
bestowed upon mile one of the four
Archangels in fact Miele was believed to
be the strongest out of the four
Archangels but he was allegedly killed
by Esther OSA three thousand years ago
after miles death sunshine somehow
passed on to Eskin orb but at this time
we don't actually know how or why that
happened what makes Eska nor so
interesting is the stark duality of his
personality the huge contrast between
the two sides of his character on the
one hand he is an incredibly powerful
pinnacle of manliness and he is so proud
and confident that you can't help but
laugh at how he looks down on his
opponents in that sense s Canora kind of
reminds me of coming up from Gurren
Lagann and if you know me then you know
that kameena is my favorite anime
character of all time so in that sense I
definitely have a special place in my
heart for s Kannur but on the other hand
despite his incredible power s Canora
had an extremely traumatic childhood
imagine being ostracized and cast out by
everyone you know because of something
that you have no control over
imagine being disowned by your own
parents and almost killed as a child
just because a strange power manifested
inside you through no fault of your own
that is exactly the type of backstory
that would make someone the opposite of
confident something like that would make
a person feel insecure and it would
leave them with major abandonment issues
and we can see this conflict raging
within esken or whether it is nighttime
or daytime s canora's feelings for
merlin betray his inner insecurities
even as he mocks his enemies for daring
to be born into the same world as him s
Kannur is clearly in love with merlin he
has great respect for her and he does
not consider himself to be superior to
her even at the height of his power
because merlin is one of the very few
people who treated s Kannur with
kindness when everyone else saw him as a
monster s Kannur is very cautious not to
screw up his relationship with merlin
because he doesn't want to lose her and
that is why he is known to act with
shyness and insecurities
her even though he is the sin of pride
esken or doesn't have the confidence to
admit his true feelings to merlin
probably because he is afraid that she
will never feel the same way about him
and he doesn't want merlin to push him
away after she learns about his true
feelings so he is torn between opening
up to merlin and keeping his feelings
hidden and this is the funny thing about
Eskin or even though during the daytime
he is such an over-the-top
larger-than-life supremely confident and
tremendously powerful warrior he is
still only human and we can all relate
to his fears and insecurities as Kannur
considers his unique power to be a curse
a curse which isolated him from his
fellow humans made him a freak and a
monster in the eyes of everyone he knew
even his own parents even though he uses
this curse to great effect in battle
ESCA noir is still haunted by his
difficult past and he is very careful
around people like Merlin because he
doesn't want the few people who actually
don't consider him a monster to turn
their back on him on the one hand s
Connor is the powerful and totally
badass Lyon sin of pride but on the
other he is just a human being wants to
be accepted and loved by others which is
something that he never even experienced
until he met Merlin and the other sins s
Kannur is clearly not a one-dimensional
character he is a nuanced and
multi-dimensional character like so many
other characters in the seven deadly
sins which is one of the biggest reasons
why I love this series as the manga goes
on I have a feeling that we are going to
see s Kannur and Merlin's relationship
develops so I am looking forward to that
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments do you like s Kannur as a
character and do you think that he will
eventually succeed in winning over
Merlin's heart also how many praise the
Sun comments are we going to get on this
video let's find out if you enjoy this
type of content be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you're new to this
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you can be
notified every time a new video is out
don't forget to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar for daily
anime content as always thank you all so
much for watching I really appreciate it
and until next time see us space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]